by the time of the late 1990s the days
of the traveling salesmen were on the
gradual decline more and more consumers
out there were being all too easily
enticed by the alluring draw of
advertisements broadcast directly into
their homes through their television
sets or beamed out over the radio
between the latest chart hits hell even
catalogs sent straight to people's
mailboxes were making it all the harder
for the door-to-door industry to stay
afloat times they were a-changing and
day working people were no longer
content to allow a total stranger to
stand on their front porch and peddle
their wares at them jerry had been at
that game for almost 20 years now he had
been born with a natural gift of the gab
that made him a real savant of sales a
michelangelo of making people part with
their hard-earned money a da vinci of
discounts and dealing if you will okay
i'll stop now sorry his fellow salesman
on the road sometimes called him mr
motormouth not to be confused with
scp-2094
they used to joke that jerry could talk
his way out of a sealed room with no
doors or windows while also convincing
said roone to pay him an exit fee as
well but as much as he had a knack for
making deals he had felt the tides
shifting lately the business of driving
across the country to sell products
direct to consumers was fast becoming a
thing of the past an almost arcane
practice in the age of the infomercial
and the catchy jingles of advertisements
companies were growing becoming far
bigger absorbing one another to the
point where they were conglomerates
corporations that could form entire
departments dedicated to marketing
campaigns for their various products
they no longer needed the work of men on
the ground talking face-to-face with
consumers even the smaller companies
were giving up on that method of
marketing choosing instead to sell their
patents and products to the big boys in
exchange for a hefty sum his job as a
door-to-door salesman was on its way to
an inevitable grave and jerry knew it
with the looming threat of occupational
redundancy on the horizon he had decided
that it was time to cash out to give up
a life on the road and either find a new
job somewhere or face the prospect of
going flat broke but it was hard to
leave the scene if you didn't have the
green between the expenses of keeping
his car in tip-top shape to take him
from state to state and the
ever-increasing cut his marketing agency
took out of his earnings jerry needed to
see out just one more quarter it
wouldn't be too hard he thought to
himself not for old mr jerry motormouth
little did he know the sales game had a
new player on the board one whose powers
of persuasion were far greater than
jerry ever could have imagined
a small company that sold its own brand
of food processors had employed the
sales agency that he worked for and
seeing as jerry was one of the few old
guard classic door-to-door salesmen that
hadn't been laid off yet or let go
yet he was off on the open road for what
he hoped would be the final time his
windows down the sweet timely sounds of
rem blasting on his radio jerry drove
into the next town on his list the last
10 places he had stopped in had all been
a nightmare for shifting units meaning
he still had boxes upon boxes of stock
to shift currently said cardboard boxes
were cramped up in the back seats of his
car with more threatening to burst from
the trunk and the towbar cargo box
affixed to the rear bumper of his old
plymouth utility but it seemed like no
matter what city town or suburb he
arrived at with his car full of food
processors to sell jerry kept finding
that he had arrived only too late oh no
thanks the homeowners he visited would
say i just bought a new food processor
the ad on tv just really sold it to me
everywhere he turned every door that he
wrapped his knuckles on all brought the
same answer with it naturally 11
locations in and barely more than a few
units sold jerry was starting to worry
his magic motor mouth had run out of
steam had he really lost his neck or was
this rival food processor manufacturer
simply pilfering all his potential
customers through their ad campaign
after another unsuccessful day those
were the only questions spinning around
and around in jerry's head as he paced
back and forth in the motel room he was
staying in the tv was on playing an ad
break between a rerun of an episode of
seinfeld just providing some light
background noise although it would soon
present the answer to jerry's questions
the chime of a catchy cheesy jingle
caught his attention first followed by
the name of the company it was the same
name jerry had heard from the lips of
every home he'd stopped at this was the
commercial that convinced them all to
buy this company's food processor over
the ones he was trying to sell grabbing
the remote jerry jabbed the button that
increased the volume he had to see how
they did it a large man considerably
overweight by some people's standards
appeared on screen and started rattling
off all sorts of details about the rival
company's food processor at first jerry
couldn't help glaring at the man like
they were bitter lifelong enemies after
all it was because of this ad that he
was missing out on potential sales and
risking not meeting his final quarterly
quota but the more he watched the
weighty man on the screen telling the
viewer how wonderful this product was it
was like jerry could feel a tiny part of
himself agreeing every word made sense
somehow like it was just right
unequivocally unquestionably
categorically correct in every way he
couldn't refute that this other food
processor despite being sold by his
client's competition
did seem like the superior product and
if any of you folks need to be persuaded
further then believe me when i tell you
this the man declared with a wide smile
on his red sweat sheen face you need
this product in your life he couldn't
argue with that jerry thought to himself
he really did need one of those food
processors it wasn't an all-consuming
uncontrollable need at least not yet but
more of a gentle compulsion that became
lodged at the back of his mind something
about the man's words had him pretty
convinced and he had to recognize and
even respect a fellow salvador dali of
the salesman's craft his demeanor wasn't
exactly what you might expect to see
from someone presenting an ad there was
no cheesy jovial banter and forced false
laughter in fact the man had been pretty
abrasive practically demanding that
viewer to buy that particular brand of
food processor and yet somehow it seemed
to leave a lasting albeit fleeting
impression on jerry an impression that
would only get worse the next day he had
decided to change his sales tactic
drawing on an old trick from his two
decades of experience after barely
selling any of his stock to homeowners
jerry figured his next best move was to
try his luck at local restaurants cafes
and any other type of business that
might have a need of a new food
processor maybe he thought to himself if
he was extremely lucky he could sell
multiple units of stock to each business
he visited making up for the lack of
sales he'd made so far but it was while
driving through the center of town that
something caught jerry's eye it was
magnetic like a moth being drawn to the
bright glare of a light bulb it was one
of the food processors from the advert
the same ones that everyone jerry had
visited had already bought there it sat
in a storefront window as if it was
practically beckoning him inside the man
on tv had told jerry he needed one for
himself and now that he could see it as
clear as day he knew that it was true
for the next few minutes it was like
jerry's brain had been set to autopilot
mode he parked his car turned the engine
off opened the door and started walking
towards the store without stopping to
think about it at all within minutes he
was not only inside but lifting a heavy
box off the shelf and carrying the shiny
new food processor the one sold by a
company that were rivals to his very own
clients up to the cashier still not
pausing to even consider what he was
doing as if he had been put in a trance
jerry opened up his wallet and parted
with his hard-earned cash paying for the
processor and carrying it back to his
car it wasn't until he sat back down in
the driver's seat that jerry seemed to
wake up only to look in horror at the
box he had just placed in the seat next
to him he blinked his face awash with
disbelief never in all his years had he
ever needed something like a food
processor he had no use for it but now
he had gone and absent-mindedly
purchased one from a rival brand no less
and it had all been because that man on
the tv had told him to he couldn't go
back to making sales that day how could
he even if he could get any of the
town's local restaurants interested in
buying the food processors he had to
sell they would immediately lose all
faith in the product the minute they
spotted a different brand of the same
device sitting pristine in jerry's car
driving back to the motel he just spent
a few hours sitting on the uncomfortable
bed staring blankly in awe at what he
had bought overcome with a sudden rush
of anger although mainly directed at
himself he hurled the box across the
room it banged loudly against the wall
then clattered to the floor but it was
just as he marched over to it about to
stomp on the food processor with his
foot that jerry spotted something
printed on the back it was hidden among
all the usual legal speak that companies
were required to have on their products
not satisfied with this product call our
customer service hotline it was those
few simple words and the string of
numbers that followed it that gave jerry
an idea the man on the tv someone at the
rival company must have hired him to
present the advertisement and if he
could find out who and get in touch with
that oddly convincing man that could be
the answer to his sales trouble little
did jerry expect that it would lead to a
whole different type of trouble
for him it definitely didn't come easy
starting with a call to the company's
customer complaints departments with the
hopes of being put through to their
advertising people was an uphill
challenge for anyone but jerry wasn't
just anyone he was mr motormouth the man
who could talk his way into and out of
anything he knew he'd have to lie
through his teeth or
bend the truth as he liked to call it
each time he claimed to be from the
federal trade commission or the united
states patent and trademark office a
cold tremble shuttered through his hands
heart pounding faster against his chest
icy sweat making his shirt stick to his
back every lie was a risk he could
easily be reported to the police for
fraud but by some miracle or maybe a
curse his phone call was passed from
department to department until he spoke
to one of the company's advertising
personnel they were careless enough to
give him the address of the man who had
been in their tv ads and it was only a
short drive across town unlike earlier
jerry was now fully aware of what he was
doing he just couldn't believe he was
actually going through with it standing
outside the front door of the man from
the advertisement the one who had
seemingly mesmerized him into buying
something he didn't even need he could
feel his pulse beating faster than ever
reaching out a shaking hand he knocked
loudly on the door the sound of movement
came from behind the door only for it to
be pulled open there he was standing in
the door frame although he'd never say
it out loud jerry couldn't help but
wonder how such a large man fit through
his own doorway he somehow looked worse
up close the cameras and makeup for the
ad must have gone a long way to mask
just how very clear it was that this man
wasn't exactly the model of perfect
health can i help you he asked abruptly
yeah sorry jerry stammered nervously
my name's jerry i i saw you on a tv ad
last night for a
food processor i'm not giving out
autographs the man wasn't just blunt he
was outright impolite beat it jerry
wait he interjected desperation making
his voice crack please just let me
explain i work in sales and i've got a
car full of similar products that i need
to get people to buy and you want me to
help with that the man predicted not
interested i only do ads if i'm getting
paid by now the sheer overwhelming
nerves that had taken hold of jerry were
quickly becoming something else hearing
how bad mannered and unaccommodating
this man was being made it hard to keep
his temper at bay frustration was
boiling over into anger and eventually
it became too much to keep down any
longer
jerry reached two hands out to the man
gripping his thick neck by the folds of
his sweat-soaked collar listen to me you
he said his voice raised as his rage
came bursting out i haven't been able to
sell one of these damn things and it's
all because of that stupid ad you were
in you even got me to buy one i still
have no idea how i'm a door-to-door
salesman for crying out loud what on
earth would i ever do with a food
processor tell me how you did it you
want to take your hands off me jerry the
man's voice was calm almost unnerving in
how reserved he was being before he had
addressed jerry dismissively but now he
spoke with a collected simplicity and it
worked somehow it worked as if his arms
were moving independently jerry watched
as his hands let go of the man's collar
staring wide eye he hadn't wanted to
take them away hadn't made an effort to
let go except the moment he was told
that he wanted to he had wanted to and
loosened his grip accordingly the man
had told him what he wanted and somehow
made it true
what are you jerry asked looking up in
horror at the large man you want to not
harm me the man replied with the same
eerie calmness to his voice but there
was something else there too
a low tone of another far crueler
cadence you want to hurt yourself though
jerry
something came speeding through the air
and caught the side of jerry's cheek the
force of the object reeled him causing
him to stagger back until he realized
exactly what had hit him it was his own
fist he punched himself no was worse
than that he had wanted to harm himself
just like the man had told him i think
what you really want the other man
continued using a tone that now swam
with even more sadistic malice is to
keep hitting yourself
the pain of another self-inflicted punch
struck jerry followed swiftly by a third
his arms were moving impulsively almost
like he had no control over them but
also as if he couldn't help but keep
doing what this man had said his fist
clenched tight an uppercut connected
with jerry's chin causing one of his
teeth to chip against the other
spluttering he spat out the fragment of
enamel followed by a mouthful of blood
and spittle let me make you an offer
that you can't refuse the men announced
for the low low price of nothing at all
keep punching yourself in the face as
hard as you can
it's the new best thing for you right
jerry don't stop until you lose
consciousness
instantly jerry's fists started
pummeling striking one after the other
the pain was pulsating through the skin
of his face stinging under his eyes
reddening and bruising every visible
part another hit connected sharply and
jerry felt the agony of his own nose
breaking the crunch of bone as more
blood spilled out of his nostrils
wetting his mouth and staining it red it
went on for hours by the time he had hit
himself enough times jerry's face was
completely unrecognizable his face was
swollen jawed dislocated and one eye so
badly bruised that it had swollen
practically shutting itself his arm
raised once more of its own accord and
came slamming down hard enough to knock
jerry out laying in a bloodied bruised
mess looking down at him
scp-661 sneered and went back into his
house slamming the door behind him jerry
wasn't the only one whose attention had
been caught by the advertisements
starring this particularly rude man they
also had garnered the scrutiny of the
scp foundation would place this
individual later known by the
designation
scp-661 under surveillance for a while
they had kept a close eye on him
monitoring his day-to-day activity to
the untrained eye he was just an
ordinary if a little overweight man
working as an advertising and marketing
agent he'd regularly star in tv and
radio ads boasting the wild assertion
that he could easily convince anyone
alive to do anything he told them now
sure arrogance is hardly a purely
anomalous trait but what the foundation
soon realized was that claim was right
testing quickly revealed that
scp-661's voice possessed some kind of
hypnotic or mesmeric influence simply by
speaking he could manipulate other
people into doing what he asked them to
do or wanting what he told them they
wanted naturally working in marketing
this made him a salesman almost too good
to be true just as long as someone could
understand the commands and suggestions
he made anyone exposed to his voice
would feel a prolonged sense of
compulsion it began as a weak feeling at
first just lingering in the back of a
person's mind like a post-hypnotic
suggestion a thought implanted by
somebody else that the subject doesn't
act on until later the effect would
normally last for around a week or until
a time when the subject was presented
with the means to actually get what
scp-661 had convinced them they wanted
say for example a physical product like
a food processor perhaps the worst part
though is that
scp-661 seems to have been aware of his
anomalous powers of influence for some
time although he claims otherwise he's
shown no problem in trying to use his
manipulative gift of the gab to convince
the foundation's personnel to release
him from their custody where he is
currently being held lucky they bought
themselves noise-cancelling headphones
those might be the only thing stopping
this slimy salesman from getting into
their heads now go and check out scp-738
the devil's deal and scp-035 the
possessive mask for more anomalies with
enticing offers for unsuspecting humans
that can promise to fulfill your deepest
desires for a price except that price
might not be worth paying